all right so this was a recommendation
from kinetic on we had a fan come up and
say be redundant Sonic the Hedgehog
movie I'm like not the one I was are you
talking about it's like no no the
there's one that you like made an
animated movie so if you hear that but
rubber attack yeah so I have no idea if
this has a good reputation a bad
reputation but I know
Sonic's a hot thing there's like has a
huge fan 99 so this is yeah I have no
idea I have no idea what we're about to
see but I am I am interested so here we
go this is Sonic the Hedgehog of the
movie OVA 1999 Sega this akira go see it
uh yeah see yeah see I see it as a sonic
a sonic a sonic sonic sonic this is
supposed to be before it got weird I
don't know this is already kind of a
weird opening it really makes you
realize how far anime has come because I
look at these I'm like yeah this is like
hand-drawn pre digital I like hand-drawn
it but it does like instantly now I'm
just like yeah this looks old
this is 1999 I think yeah I look back to
1999 and would have thought this looks
perfectly fine
oh something happened there it's a
jet-propelled body boy come on you let
it dry down tails
nobody likes you this is all the
introduction we need I guess man that
just wins my chili dog that's Mickey I
think one of the main design flaws of
Sonic for me is that I find all of the
characters outside of Sonic and knowing
I'm not a tails man I really like
knuckles Hedgehog is like yeah yeah I
don't know perfect your higher welcome
to old school take everything just push
the plane he's so fast
Roosevelt no seriously they rose in the
big Sonic's is like holy Jesus
every man will you stand fun da da he'd
meet me there I lived peacefully
I like this evil lurking city is like I
lived peacefully in my Dark Kingdom of
doom battalion of demonic of robots
peacefully I'm Iran and it should be the
fastest one here get about it you say
you Sonic I don't care what happens
to Robotnik or daddy but please just do
this my dad just gave me wife as long as
you have that with you we should take
you to robotropolis using the shortest
and fastest accent trying to figure it
out I am Eternia doesn't it usually free
animals I'm free sure that when he just
cut into ribbons and like that one was
evil
bees don't have souls bad are we in the
very far future and Sonic's been on
earth all along that's the twist now
you're going to die even though one of
you can obviously fly they're both made
no sense end rhymes
good night tails so this must be the
entrance to real boat strapless that
sounds like such a made of kid name
it's called propolis maybe they have
dinosaurus assistants but that's a
dinosaur a phallus
I really should call this movie knuckles
because he's doing the majority of the
work you know somebody doing animating
that parts so this is basically a metal
sonic gorgeous even though it's called
Sonic the Hedgehog the movie so it
should be about silent but no it's about
Metal Sonic and whoever these people are
ok then Metal Sonic is looking into my
soul I can't look at anything else when
that thing is on screaming he's got a
spike for an ass that's terrifying
there's no way that either one of us is
going to be able to chase them down like
this obviously we have to give up if we
just submit to Robotnik I'm sure he will
treat us fairly I turned it to Muppet
Satan I love drinking Shaq sonic it's
you welcome back initiate kill protocol
nice to see you too come back in the
owl's severed head is on a pike could
this be the work of metal Robotnik I'm
so glad we had that inner monologue for
that even though we had no other inner
monologues he deserved it to wonder if
it was the bad guy doing the bad things
I wonder when this was me there it's
just don't understand
I'm extreme to the maxi euro I don't
drink the purple stuff hey this is the
president you listen to me right yelling
who are you I'm not goes I'm Sonic's
best friend I see I see
it's just that sodium as you say I see
the land of the sky is held together by
a huge glacier which joins the
continents beneath Cora says the science
sukkah science report written by Alex
Jones it's sonic just yeah dude
that just say something's gonna blow
up we don't need the technical
surface so did I heard your 80s sound
effect sonic just disappeared from here
he must be a cuckoo cuckoo girl it won't
shock me at this body he sends it to a
werewolf later why not a ghost I just
like saying good good good good
quiet buckle up and hang on we're
getting a warp zone what is happening
what is happening that awful this is a
kids movie like I can't follow it the
universe has a lot of repeated stars
there looks like og pan rule 34 me you
pervert
my god that boy did she told you he just
sit on his face
yes she totally just said again as he
has probably paused a lot should we be
grateful deviantART wasn't around when
this was really I think it was born from
this movie Sonic it's really weird
Sonic what's going on here Sonic I have
no idea why do not weep for me I am
already dead you were the chosen one I
hate you man the robot still is better a
human you were supposed to bring balance
to the video game franchise don't
destroy it again very fitting a Sonic
you tried to kill me I respect that
I don't think we've learned it there
[Laughter]
goddamn thing what have we gained from
this squat
oh my copy of Sonic CD no it's even more
worthless than it was originally is it
weird to say this is kind of how I see
real-life politics working oh just a
bunch of that makes no sense and it
results in nothing but a lot of
destruction I don't even know what to
say to that and just I mean I followed
it easier than the pokemons I think that
movie made the instruction book to like
explain the backstory game's use down
anyone that has never seen or heard of
Sonic the Hedgehog this will answer all
your questions this is somewhere in
between the Saturday morning cartoon and
the afternoon cartoon that ran yeah that
was so beyond goofy and made zero sense
and the Saturday morning cartoon took
itself way more seriously like this is
somewhere dead set in the middle or it's
like or it's a little serious it's a
little more well drawn it's also goofy
yeah it has like it has the serious look
of the sad a.m. one but it has like the
goofy nonsensical riding of the other
one we will just see you next time bye
fastest thing lies
I really won't watch that again actually
so do i Sally was hot didn't record
I said
[Laughter]
you